it's time for seeing and unseen where we
explore the stories behind the headlines
and for that we turn to fox news
contributor
raymond arroyo all right raymond let us
start
with this piece in the atlantic where
the writer
is attempting to villainize those who
pray the rosary i've heard it all
laura daniel panittin penned a piece
titled how the rosary became an
extremist symbol stay with me the
atlantic later altered the title but it
reads this way the battle beads culture
of spiritual warfare permits radical
traditional catholics literally to
demonize their political opponents and
regard the use of armed force against
them as sanctified the sacramental
rosary isn't just a spiritual weapon but
one that comes with physical ammunition
now laura are catholics out strangling
people with rosary beads or
are they loading rosary beads at the
cannons and firing them on pagans i
don't think so i couldn't find one case
where either thing happened not once
well raymond
um
just because of that article
you sent it to me or i sent it to you
last night
i had the kids we did all five decades
of the rosary last night and i think
it's been quite a while since i've done
that so what i'm saying is i'm looking
at the glass half full because they
demonized the rosary i felt that must be
something i should be doing more of
so that's right it is a spiritual weapon
to combat the devil and look
christians have been praying this for
centuries and it's just a scriptural
recitation and meditation very
structured using our father hail mary's
but here's the point this writer is
obviously uh filled with some kind of
religious animus and he's really afraid
of faith because it was praying the
rosary that brought down the iron
curtain in poland ended roe v wade and
maybe that's what's got him so scared
but here's the bewildering thing to me
the atlantic is demonizing catholics for
praying the rosary while we have a
high-profile stabbing of renowned author
salman rushdie
which increasingly appears to be
religiously motivated and everyone is
suddenly utterly confused
while we wait to hopefully hear an
update about his condition the other big
question is a possible motive it's
chilling it's intimidating and it's it's
it's terror um we don't know the motive
what could that motive be laura what
could have provoked a suspect hadi matar
to stab salman rushdie matar's own
mother by the way says he was a shiite
and is a shiite and after spending a
month in lebanon became very moody and
more religious might the fatwa the
iranian government pronounced on rushdie
had been a contributing factor
[Music]
i mean
a spokesman for the iranian foreign
ministry who says rushdie brought the
attack upon himself
[Music]
[Music]
so justifying the fatwa raymond
he justified it is that confusing to uh
the atlantic
they they're i guess not but they won't
touch this with a 10-foot blade and
here's the problem you've got middle
eastern intelligence officers saying
that this suspect had contact with the
iranian revolutionary guard so there's
real facts to report here and
everybody's looking the other way
scratching their head if you're looking
for religious driven extremism you don't
have to look very far meanwhile in
pennsylvania lore democratic candidate
for senate john fetterman returned to
the campaign trail three months after
suffering a stroke his return was a
little less than fluid
25
of those counties more votes 25 out of
those 50 there's 54 red counties more
votes more votes than dr oz in those
counties as well too who would ever
think that i would be
the normal the normal one in the race
area with that i gave away the
i gave away the lieutenant governor
governor in pennsylvania the only
lieutenant governor in the history to do
that you can count
on us
to eliminate the filibuster
[Applause]
[Music]
eliminate the filibuster
and let's
let's get some stuff
done for america if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stay and with you in
dc
poor guy i mean look he suffered a
stroke he's back on the trail but after
joe biden uh joe john fetterman looks
like churchill but he's obviously
struggling with syntax laura and
you you might say even his supporters
told abc news they found him wandering
one of them said he lacked energy
he should be focused on his health here
for the good of the party for the good
of his his uh reputation maybe it's time
to step away from the trail rather than
lean into it uh well the whole costume
with the hoodie and the sweatpants i
mean the whole it's just not serious i'm
just all right the uncle faster garb
that didn't do it for you now were you
the one who came up with uncle festerman
that's such an easy joke but i don't
like the whole hoodie i mean okay if
you're 13 and you're going to practice
that's fine but a grown man we don't
need the hoodie thank you very much
that's aside from the fact that nothing
he said will make the lives of
pennsylvanians any better yeah the
policies of what matter but no no this
uh oz has got to close this gap and the
people of pennsylvania can do a lot
better raymond thank you great to see
you tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else